somebody that's currently in prison
galen maxwell
i believe she spent
approximately 500 days in isolation
so um
it's a very difficult different prison
experience
but what do you think about her case
what do you think about her and jeffrey
epstein
she
so
her brother her family
she says that
she's a victim
not the monster
i think this is an especially
fascinating case because um
and i've i have
listened to podcasts about the you know
the epstein situation
um
and there was one that was more focused
on her by vicki ward that i would
definitely listen to
um
vicki ward
is a journalist i think she'd written an
article about jeffrey epstein for vanity
fair so she got to know jeffrey epstein
and then she knew colleen maxwell um
from being sort of part of the
social circle in which they would have
overlapped have you by the way ever met
them since this new york
do you remember meeting this
you know uh
jeffrey or
or gillian
no i never met them but they're also
very much like this sort of upper east
side crowd um i did meet harvey
weinstein once that made me have all
kinds of interesting thoughts later
at the restaurant or elsewhere no it was
weird it was out on the street
and we had this really strange
interaction
and
knowing what i know now
it was eerie and and also like had he
contacted me after that
and made it seem like he could have done
something for me like would i have been
you know say he said oh i'm gonna
finance your whole expansion or
something and
like come to my you know come meet me at
this hotel and then i go to that hotel
and then he's like come up to the room
and then i would have been like uh
and you're wondering whether you would
have done it yes and sadly i think i
would have and so i felt a lot of
compassion for
um
those who
you know didn't
yell at him and leave or didn't storm
out
and because i think
what happens in those situations
is um
you know there's all kinds of
uncertainty in the moment and you sort
of freeze and then you'll
if
i'm probably one of those people that
would
sit there and somehow in the moment
without clarity
just instinctively feel like somehow i
must have done something wrong and it's
my fault and and like i led him on and
or just being afraid and then and then
you don't know how to deal with it and
so you freeze
um
so i think that
you know if you're somebody that
maybe was raised differently or you have
a lot of self-confidence or
um you might have
reacted differently and kind of
pushed them away and stormed out
um
but
i am probably not one of those people
but i did not ever meet jeffrey epstein
but he seems very straightforwardly um
you know just a classic the way he was
able to charm people the way he
could step into these roles um
you know i think he was teaching at
dalton and then
just kind of the way he would get
himself into the
the academic crowd within harvard and i
think also mit right he's sort of
so he's playing a role but he's doing it
so well that he fools all these people
and what and the things that people
would
in hindsight say about him
are just the same things that people say
about it's like you hear the same things
over and over again you hear the same
thing said about those people who were
taken in by elizabeth holmes is that
they were like
it was as if he was under a spell it was
as if i was under a spell
is something you hear a lot and so it's
like they have this
powerful charm that's almost over it's
overwhelming in that they overwhelm your
better judgment or they overwhelm your
like normal
otherwise normally functioning capacity
for
rational thought and they sort of
overwhelm that with their charm so
you know when you look at i think it was
like james mattis invested a bunch of
money with elizabeth holmes and
all these people were involved with her
um
and nobody really did their due
diligence where they just sort of
trusted her
and jeffrey epstein i think it's still
unclear where he got all of his money
but the guy wexner
les wexner
who had you know
an enormous amount of money and somehow
very quickly turned over management of
it to jeffrey epstein and so people
wonder like why would he do that that's
insane
and and and then other people have
commented
about that relationship like it was as
if he was under jeffrey's spell you know
observers would say i couldn't
understand it it was as if he was under
his spell and so somebody observing
me and mr fox could have possibly said
the same thing about me but it's a bit
different because it wasn't all charm i
think um
epstein used his charm and then was
probably very very very crafty and
getting another thing that people like
him do and cults do also is to get um
is to get you somehow compromised
because then they've got you
so i think some kind of
usually sex related
yeah and with epstein certainly you know
he was known to have cameras everywhere
and so if he got any of these people on
camera doing something compromising and
all very powerful people
then he's got them
um and i think he was also very smart to
do that to target people of both parties
so that politically
that he was able to maintain his power
like no matter
like
nobody wanted him to be totally exposed
because then
people
a lot of people would be exposed um by
the way that part you know
that's all kind of
conspiracy right
right we don't know that
i
so a lot of people believe that and
you know i tend to kind of naturally
believe that because that makes sense
but it's also possible that
straight up with charisma
i mean he did record people and there
were recordings so
i listened to an interview with a woman
who i mean was a girl back then maybe
she was 15 or 16 back then
um
and
subsequently
years later
was able to see some of the video of
i mean i think that's a verifiable thing
that there were video cameras all over
his house yeah the degree to which it
was used
right we don't know that
and um
to the degree of how many people were
involved and so on there's all kinds of
conspiracies around the man but the
question about
her
her galen
so
i only know what i know from the inputs
which are
the vicky ward
it was it's a pod it's one of the
podcasts it's a narrative podcast so
it's like a
um it's like an audio kind of a
documentary or journalistic piece that
she did and put out
i thought it was really really well done
i think it's called chasing galen
um
and i listened to that whole thing
i didn't intend to listen to it all
in one stretch that's how you know it's
good i mean it was like a weekend and i
basically was
you know cleaning and doing other things
and walking leon and listening to it and
i got through it pretty quickly but i
got really fascinated by it because um
i don't i don't know but i think
i feel
like i find the whole situation
gut-wrenching because i think
jeffrey epstein is a straight-up like
straight-up
sociopath like
no question
with her
everybody's calling her
evil
and
for her to have enabled and done a lot
of the things that she did
could potentially require
one might say that it could require a
lack of empathy to be able to do those
things
knowingly
but at the same time
i think
the the information that was conveyed in
the vicki ward
piece
was fascinating to me because it's clear
that at the very least it's like it's
like all of these things could be true
she could maybe be
not enough of a good person to have
you know horribly victimized these young
girls and destroy their lives but she
could have all
i feel like i'm going to get bashed for
saying this but she could have in some
way have
not quite known what she was doing or
been a bit out of her mind
i'm just saying people i i would hope
that people would be open to that's
to exploring that as a possibility well
her family and friends are making that
case
they're they're painting
uh
a broad picture of who she is as a human
being and
showing that she couldn't have done any
of those things
without being
like
systematically manipulated
that's their right what i listened to
in that podcast about
her relationship with her father
the star uh how her father died um
her things about her childhood and then
epstein coming into her life and
basically kind of pushing all those
buttons and becoming like the father
figure and so she would be in a position
of kind of always wanting his approval
and
um and just the way that
things that are described about the way
that she
um
like was so subservient to him
in this kind of astonishing way that
seems really weird and abnormal
and yet i think she had a lot of
money and connections and i think she
lost the money but had all the
connections either way there was a lot
that a ton that epstein gained via
his relationship with her like a ton
so
it makes sense that he would have
manipulated her he manipulates everybody
so he
without question i think one could argue
he definitely manipulated her
and again i want to be like careful not
to be
saying like that's an excuse for what
she did
i just think that
that's one possibility it's important to
like
explore these things and be open to them
as opposed to just
like broad brush painting her as a
horrible person i mean
because people could say that based on
things they've
read or things that i did that like i'm
a horrible person and it's very it's
it's com very different because what she
did involved
um
you know young girls whose lives were
destroyed
but i think that
people
could
be a bit open to understanding how
somebody could be manipulated
there's a there's a psychologist that
i'm
friends with that i got to know
after i watched him on um
leah remini's show so leah remini is the
actress who was in scientology got out
and has
really been speaking out about it and
trying to expose
what they're all about and how
diabolical that organization is and a
lot of people are exposing them and um
you know
doing this type of work
and so she had this guy on her show who
was in the moonies
and his name is um steve haasen
and
um so he was in a cult and then he got
out again by extreme circumstances he
got in a car accident and almost died
and that's
what ended up getting him out of the
cult that he was in but really smart guy
um was targeted when he was young got
pulled into the moonies
but watching this interview of him on
her show
he said he's talking about his
experience and he said if they had told
me to kill somebody i would have
and i
that in that moment made me cry but i
also felt
like
i understand that
and not that if mr fox had told me to
kill somebody i don't think i would have
but again i understand how it could get
to that point
so that makes me feel like with her
like i would be curious what steve
hassan would think kind of analyzing the
entire situation
because it's hard to understand that
unless you've been in it and i
understand with him how he could have
said that if they had told me to kill
somebody i would have
that's pretty intense i mean that's
pretty extreme
and it's interesting how you can get
into it
how far you can go just one day at a
time like gradually right just
like
the frog in the boiling water
you